[Music]
on the show you guys have famously
invented an app what apps do you guys
use in real life what do you exactly do
you use for an app I'm pretty wary of
most tech but I've recently started
using an app called soothe which is a
uber for massage and the way it works is
you press a button and then a massage
therapist who you only know their first
name shows up your house and it's all
the relaxation of a massage with all
this suspense of possibly being murdered
in your own home it's a real thing
that's a real thing but wait a minute so
you know nothing about these people have
you had a good experience I've had
yeah mixed experiences I got one for my
girlfriend recently and the guy showed
up and he looked like Bronson you know
that Tom Hardy character it's pretty
obscure reference but it's basically a
bald skinhead with the giant handlebar
mustache and murder eyes I'm leaving now
I mean that's a very strange thing to do
yeah well I'm relaxed and also in all
like constantly in a low-grade state of
terror when this show premiered we were
at South by Southwest and they have a
big tech component and when I was eating
in the lobby I heard a guy pitching his
app to another person for the tech
conference and he described it as the
Ghandi of apps so tech people really are
as horrific as we make I was at
TechCrunch there's a TechCrunch Disrupt
which is in the show is the real thing
yep and TJ and I were at it at the end
of first season and someone came up to
pitch us an app that he had made and not
realizing that TJ and I are pretty like
staunch atheist he says I've got an app
it prays for you and we were like what
and it was like you just select your
religion what and it will pray on your
behalf and I was like you don't know how
spirituality works my friend
I hope God has an app that just
automatically sends you to hell yeah
it's kind of a left swipe right swipe
deal god
smite save
you